- It's so funny because years
ago when you were on "Idol",
that was a big surprise
that my family presented
me and my brother with, that we would go
and see the show.
- I remember you telling
me this, yes!
- And I'll never forget, I
was sitting in the audience
and my dad looked at me and was like,
"It's gonna be you one day."
We were far up there, right?
Lookin' down on the stage
and it still felt so massive
and my dad was like,
"That's gonna be you one day."
And I was like,
"No, it's not." (laughs)
- That's so cool!
Oh, yeah.
(audience laughs)
That's great though.
- It seemed so far away,
but, I don't know,
to now be sitting here
with you on this show,
it's so special.
- Oh, what a great daddy!
That's awesome!
(audience applause and cheers)
Speaking of your dad, (laughs)
when we worked together
before, I had no idea
your dad was a personal trainer
and then I saw a picture
and I was like, what?
- Yep, that's us, that's us.
- [Kelly] Yeah, so do y'all
work out all the time?
- We do, yeah.
- Look at that!
(audience applause and cheers)
I mean, that's crazy!
Is it cool to workout with
him or are you kinda like,
dad, lay off!
- That doesn't work anymore.
- Oh. (laughs)
- It used to for a while.
That was like, you know,
that was the excuse.
"Dad, this hurts."
And he's like, "Okay, we'll change it up."
And now it's like,
I go to him with certain
goals that I wanna achieve
and he knows what he has
to do to get me there.
So, no remorse.
- That's kind of awesome
though, you have a dad that...
That's really, really cool.
Okay, well whatever Haley
and her dad do, it's working.
I need to show you this
pic we took a while back
at "The Voice"
and I was like, what?
- Oh, no. (laughs)
- Like, her abs.
(audience applauds and cheers)
'Cause I used to be fit, like
I used to like working out
and then I turned 30, but um.
(audience laughs)
- Right. (laughs)
- And I was like, wait, I don't like this.
(audience chuckles)
But, does he have you doing, like...
'Cause I worked out a lot and
I never got abs like that.
Like, are you doing just
like, 3000 crunches a day?
- Every day,
3000 is the number.
- Oh!
(audience laughs)
You're joking.
- No.
- Holy gah!
Oh my gosh!
You'd have to have like,
something like wine
sitting in front of you to keep...
I'd be like,
I'm gonna get it!
- Everything under the sun
you could think of.
Donuts, pizza,
is all right in front of me.
- Oh my gosh!
- Yep.
- That was crazy, I was like, super hot!